[Music]
ever since I first saw this the magical
City of Petra in
Jordan it just hasn't left my
mind it's one of the most beautiful
unusual and iconic cities in the
world but I've learned something
surprising Petra is not the beginning of
the story It's The End there's another
lost city carved into the Rock somewhere
near
here I'm hoping to find the hidden
origins of one of the greatest cities in
the world's ever
seen my name is Albert Lynn
and I look at the world in a unique way
I use 21st Century Technologies to look
back into the
past check that out I can actually fly
through the secret ancient
world lasers that scan
deserts strip away dense jungle canopy
and scour the oceans to uncover the
Hidden Worlds
beneath we're waiting into uncharted
waters that's what a real lost city
looks like new discoveries in the most a
inspiring places on Earth that's where
pixels become reality that fill the gaps
in our story who we are where we came
from and the Wonders we can
achieve here we are in the 1 cental wow
this is carved out of the earth huh this
is the new Golden Age of
Exploration we know their
[Music]
secrets the people who lived here in
this city were they're originally
Nomads traveling trading across the
Arabian Desert living in
tents and then in a leap they built
this what
[Music]
happened I want to find out who they
were where they came from and what came
before all
this new clues about them they're being
discovered in the desert
[Music]
rocks
my journey was taken me to the deserts
of Jordan once home to the Builders of
Petra a nomatic tribe known as the
neans today these deserts are still
traveled but by their distant cousins
bids Mohammad Duman is one of
them
[Music]
oh oh
la very
good this is the most epic car I've ever
been in we don't have brakes the door
doesn't work and you have only wires as
Keys we don't have a break maybe we
enter to the camera
Muhammad is the Antiquity supervisor for
an area that covers 280 square miles of
desert called Wy
rum is this it yeah
here he's helping me find clues about
the ancient civilization who traveled
and traded here around 400
BC this one netian writing
here that's nean
yeah what does it say he write his name
and regards for regards like welcome or
yeah yeah yeah so this is a welcome
message from the nebes yeah from this
guy the nean merchants who crossed this
Desert 2 and a/ half thousand years ago
left signs for each other in the
Rocks they're incredible camels yeah
this like a sign for
Caravan like you see this camel like
this they go to the South they tell you
where the direction to go to the
water ancient
signposts out here in the
desert Muhammad scans the ancient
rockart into an app on his phone this
allows him to build a database in the
cloud now I take a picture for
rockart and I and that picture has a a
geospatial tag on it yeah I keep it so
then you collect these Geo tags yeah
across the entire landscape yeah and
then bring to life the nean trade route
each one of these walls is like the
pages of a book telling the story of the
neans names how they lived yeah yeah
everything we're in
business we follow the direction the
ancient camels pointing and head for the
nearest water
source
like the nebens before him Muhammad and
his fellow bedin set up camp around
water holes in the
[Music]
rum we upload the scans of the geotagged
rock markings and a pattern begins to
emerge this is a actually the spot that
we were so you've collected all of those
points around every sing everywhere
place you have a lot of inscription you
will find settlement or spring of the
water
wow you know looking at my GPS track of
the sites that Muhammad showed me today
there's a clear
link signs carved into rock pointing to
water that's how the neans work that was
their their secret
sauce they knew where the water
[Music]
was with that knowledge they create a
huge network of trade routes crossing
the harshest Landscapes on
Earth they import exotic goods from
Africa and
India to sell to the Greeks Egyptians
and
Romans
their most profitable product is
this
frankincense the Romans alone buy the
modern equivalent of $180 Million worth
every
year as the money rolled in their desire
to settle seems to have grown but I'm
told that Petra might not have been the
first place they put down
roots
[Music]
[Applause]
we're now flying over the ganian desert
in a
Blackhawk now I have the military
helping me find LW
cities Bob buy is an aerial
archaeologist he traces the ancient
water sources and trade routes of the
naans from
above
so what we're looking at is connection
of these blue dots and we're trying to
see how they all join
up you know every time we fly we see
things so on the end of that Hill you
can see something the whole landscape is
full of archaeology what you have to try
and do is find out which bits an have a
in and which aren't and that's the
hardest
thing okay let's open up the door
right
get oh
man can you see the track there Albert
on on the left hand side where along the
along the ridge there right there yeah
yeah
okay and although we're looking at the
Modern
Road it's built on the ancient Road and
now we're going to follow
it ancient writings suggest that
somewhere along this highway lies a nean
city hidden in the mountains one that
predates Petra by hundreds of
years oh it's got to be this I can see
the mod it's highway but you can see the
ancient Highway running right next to
it okay level off level off straight
ahead that's it lovely so that's the
track running up the hill
there we approach a Barren
Mountaintop surrounded by steep valleys
Lely 11:00 right here okay I see
it this Rocky Plateau doesn't look like
any lost city I've ever seen
before but the ancient Greek writings
describe the nomadic nepes setting up
home here possibly for the first
time happy yeah
yeah
fantastic the city is called Cella
Hebrew for rock that's amazing is it
look at that
[Applause]
dust we just landed on the ancient
Highway Cella has never been scanned by
lasers
before I'm launching an expedition to
the summit 3,000 ft above sea level with
my light our team to uncover the secrets
of this mysterious
[Music]
place I'm 1 mile West now the Old
Highway and I've hit a wall
literally deep within that Mountain
Range High up on one of the plateaus is
the ancient city of
CA the only way
in is
up
the scanning kit is being loaded up
ready for the
Expedition the Light Art team and I are
heading to one of the last fully
unexplored nean
sites and Jordan's acclaimed
archaeologist Muhammad naar is leading
the
ascent how are you my friend to see yeah
it's been too
long it's a treacherous hike to the
top Muhammad has assembled a team with
local knowledge to help
us including surveyor Ahmed
marafi ammed nice to meet you nice to
meet you
too is going to
[Music]
Bal Hey Joe hey man how's it going good
to see wow I've never carried liar kit
on a donkey before or on a horse
this is high-tech meets ancient Tech
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah are we ready let's go
y y y my friend
y I don't know what to expect at the
top what I do know is we're heading to
3,000 ft above sea level and it's going
to be a tough
climb it's like a
maze yes it
is
those steps are those yes yeah that's
our way up
wow this is the only way to climb to sa
uh there's no other
way the steps are the first hint that
this a mountain has been shaped by
people it's got to be 90° out here right
now
yeah what what you
[Music]
do this is like a ancient skyscraper up
here
incredible you know it's funny when you
walk through here you can almost
sense the path of somebody walking
through this same little canyon yeah the
exact same stairs exact same 2,000 years
ago or more so we can smell the history
right well I smell donkey farts
but this would be an intense commute for
[Music]
Naan 1,000 steps and we're only halfway
up the vertical
climb the terrain is brutal and the
questions keep
coming it just seems like an
unbelievable amount of effort to build
your World on top of a mountain in the
middle of an arid desert on should we
take a break and drink some water
guys stay away from the mean
donkey you know water is
like it's how you live but this desert
is so
dry how do you survive on top of a
mountain surrounded by dirt and no
rivers nearby nothing to farm how could
you hold out
[Music]
feels like we're getting
close this way
[Applause]
huh finally we reached the top look at
these steps huh yeah
anent that's
incredible the 360 Viewpoint for the
entire
area you can imagine that somebody stood
here thousands of years ago keeping an
eye out for the rest of their
Community that's why it's a natural
Fortress
[Music]
if this is the place named in the
ancient Greek texts then it was once a
treasury for navaan silver worth 10
million Us in today's
money its location a formidable
stronghold but how did this lifeless
crop with no water source become home to
a city of
[Music]
people to hunt for Clues we plan to lar
scan the whole
Plateau the access to so much of it is
is virtually impossible it also looks
like sheer drops bewhere I mean it's
deadly basically to explore this AB so
hopefully we can go places that wouldn't
be safe to go otherwise okay we're good
to
go this is a very dangerous place to fly
it's risky location yeah we're going to
have to to have all eyes on the drone at
all
times this is like super Advanced drone
playing yeah this is super super expert
model this is level 10
sure it's hard to believe this Barren
place was once home to hundreds even
thousands of
people if they left any evidence I'm
banking on my technology to find
it
30 Mi north of Petra I'm laser scanning
the ancient city of Cella for the very
first
time I'm looking for clues that the
nomadic neans settled
here look at this there's Pottery just
like falling out of the ground that's
the indication for people living here
this is somebody's fingerprint yes
exactly my finger fits perfectly so
somebody that's crazy you can just feel
somebody's fingerprint right here Locked
In Time mhm unbelievable the pottery
proves people were here but it's not
clear
who it could simply be the guards
charged with protecting the naptin
treasure look at this you got a
staircase where does it
go
[Music]
up probably it's a place to pray yes
absolutely you think so yeah you look
for a high place to be closer to the to
the Gods
[Music]
so far all I've found is a piece of
pottery and an ancient Stairway to
Heaven I guess this is all Sandstone
right yes it is so over 2,000 years the
landscape has sort of melted
away the Desert Winds and winter rains
are eroding the soft Sandstone into
strange shap
shapes but I can just make out curious
regular markings in the
Rocks wow look at that what are these
little holes up here actually this is
the traditional natian house so they
were living here and you can see the
marks of the axe that we have they've
been using to carving yes these are
chisel marks yes exactly somebody was
just sitting here chiseling away
creating a a space for their family
maybe MH carving caves into dwellings
suggest that they spent long stretches
of time
here look at the beautiful view here and
it's
unbelievable this is the East the sun
will come up it will be sunny in this
part the Cave's position reveals a
reason for the strange regular markings
above the
entrance their post holes for their tent
poles you have this you know shelter in
front of your house so they've gone from
living in tents to combining tents with
living in stone
[Music]
then the evidence is stacking up that
homes were created at
Cella but it's hot exposed and desert
dry without a single water source on the
whole out
crop no one can survive without water so
how did the
neans I'm hoping my lar data can help
solve the
mystery so we hiked up here right yes
yeah right there it's a lot easier from
a computer isn't it yeah is yeah it is I
think this is the way to look at theide
because if you look at small small part
you cannot I mean we need to look at the
whole side together and then you can
understand the Dynamics looks like it's
starting to be shaped by human hands no
that's that's that's true that's true I
mean look at that look look at this
picture the lar data reveals water tanks
cut into the Rock almost invisible to
the naked eye after 3 days of scanning
we've logged an incredible 51
underground tanks here at Cella it's the
first time anyone has uncovered the
extent of rainwater
harvesting you have to channel the water
the rain water they run off from the
face of the rock to the to these
systems we can now estimate that these
man-made tanks contain about 200,000
gallons of rainwater plenty to sustain
over a th000 permanent settlers it's an
exciting Discovery they were Nomads at
the beginning they were like wind you
know and the and then they they they
there there was a shift in their
Consciousness I mean they started to be
attached to the land so they that's very
important moment when they moved from
tents to caves they're turning the
landscape into a home a permanent
home our lar data transforms what we
know of
[Music]
Salah the nepan ingenuity and knowledge
of water enables them to settle living
together in a permanent City here in the
dry Rocky
desert it's a stepping stone to
Petra the journey has
[Music]
begun
you know I really feel like on this
journey of Discovery I'm connecting back
in time with the neb people you know
their travels across shifting Sands well
eventually they
settled carved a home into a solid rock
and with that added
security came a new layer of life life
in the
city and here and Aman at the Jordan
Museum I'm told that there's a lot more
evidence of that
Evolution from Nomad to
Petra inside the museum are relics that
reveal a spectacular unexpected leap in
the nebane story
story finely carved statues that look
ancient Greek and
Roman yet these are
nean gathered from a city that boomed
after Cella these carvings suggest that
their architecture is shifting from
survival to
opulence scanning the relics will allow
us to fit them back where they
belong so
cool instantaneously I can create a 3D
model of this facade but just getting up
close here you can I mean you can
actually see the Chisel the Chisel marks
and
it's feels like you can you almost sense
the moment that the neans are coming
into their their age their
Renaissance now let's get the Gemini so
what I what I have to to do is I just
have to do a a really steady
scan and we're actually using the
camera
on the data pad that's creating
something called structured
light and if I can do it steady enough
from that little sweep generate a mesh
and see it's doing it now look at
that wow
and I'll add up a series of these
different models to one awesome
model but the neans never thought this
would be
happening to reunite these relics with
their original
buildings I'm back on an ancient nean
trading
route one that leads to the ruins of
Herber Ed Daria
archaeologists are still Excavating this
city but it's clear something
extraordinary was happening
here my guide is surveyor ammed
marafi okay Albert this is the naon
city this is a new
thing
this is a design a layout that was
created by somebody's mind MH to try
something new
mhm we're going to build
walls somebody's going to be over here
and they're going to have a house over
there and then somebody's going to have
a place to cook over here somebody's
sitting in a bath house right over
there that's true and I'm sure they were
very happy this is a completely new
idea
mhm it seems like they were you know
incrementally moving forward right you
start out as a as a nomadic society and
then and then Cella you know that's step
one and then
this there's another
Innovation this city has a central
focus a
temple you know the temple we go
the naian Kings they sacrificed the
animals here on this alar right there
yeah right
there walk me through the process I'm a
natine king now I stand here in front of
this altar mhm what happens next first
you have to walk around the holy
[Music]
place
up here now yeah
up so we are now on the
altar so you lay your animal here and
what happens cut the throat to let the
blood go inside these
holes these little holes these are these
are blood holes yeah this are blood
holes blood spilled from animals went
down these holes that's
[Music]
true the statues I scanned at the Museum
once adorned the facade of this
Temple to create a complete vision of
this new netian sight requires a full
digital
scan it's the first time this has ever
been
done it's a complex
undertaking demanding detailed scanning
from the air and on the
[Music]
ground merging the data creates a new
vision of this spectacular long lost
Temple
[Music]
crowning the temple are the museum
relics back in their original
home this place reveals the evolution
from their starter City at
Salah 40 m away in Petra
nean Builders take City design to a
whole new
level I'm heading back to the ancient
wonder that is
Petra here the neans put everything
they'd learned about creating cities to
the
test look at
that
just like it
Cella these are post holes for like a
veranda it would have been wood
structures beams coming out here maybe
with some cloth or something to create
shade with time as more set up home here
the city swells in
size the money flows in and the
architecture becomes more elaborate
incorporating Styles seen on their
travels like I'm
witnessing the transition of the neans
Through Time right
here by the time of Christ Petro was the
Beating Heart of a thriving nean
[Music]
Empire from here they controlled the
trade routes from south to North and
east to
[Music]
west their wealth soared and in Petra
they flaunted
[Music]
it hidden in an upscale part of town
called little Petra is a show home for
the
time to get in there I need special
permission and a special guide her Royal
Highness Princess Donna farz I've never
been showed one of the Wonders of the
World by a real life
Princess
amazing I think that should be our new
series together yes I I'm
[Laughter]
[Music]
game don't look you cannot look just
I'll lead you
tucked away in a rock cut Villa is
tantalizing evidence of a Petra that
once
was I'm not looking I'm not looking
don't
look
okay there's something right above me
I'm not allowed to look at it yet this
is very
special now okay yeah keeping my eyes
shielded take a step up okay turn back
back okay now look
[Music]
up isn't that
wonderful it's beautiful look at the
colors
wow this changes everything
recent restoration of this Fresco
portrays Petra as Lush fertile and
green you have grap Vines you have
IV you have all sorts of food look at
the birds see the birds this one's
flying
in it's everywhere it's everywhere on
every wall yeah you can find look
there's you know the birds the FAA the
Flora the flutes the the flutes it's
that person holding a bow looks like
there's a little bow that almost looks
like a Little
[Music]
Valentine for me up until now Petra was
just
sandstone and then all of a
sudden yeah there's a whole another face
to it what I'm looking at isn't a
description of a desert this looks like
uh
Paradise it does right
carbon dating places this Fresco in the
first century ad when some 30,000 people
were living in
Petra transforming their desert city
into the Lush Oasis her Royal Highness
showed me must have required vast water
reserves far greater than those at Cella
I see all these they almost look like
staircases but they seem a little too
steep on all the these would have been
water channels they would have been
man-made carved uh channels to direct
the water during the rainy
season water harvesting was critical for
the naans they were really good at Water
engineering they were able to direct the
water or find collection points keep it
in in ssts throughout the rainy
season these tanks once contained over
10 million gallons of
water they were Master Engineers Master
Traders fantastic politicians as well
and it was part of why they became such
an influential and Wealthy
civilization and this extraordinary
civilization went on to attempt the
impossible to turn the mountains and the
sand sea that surrounded them into vast
tracks of Farmland to feed a booming
population
new evidence coming from the wind swept
Hinterlands Beyond Petra is beginning to
reveal how they greened the
[Music]
desert 2,000 years ago Petra is as big
as Beverly Hills with a population of
around 30,000
people
today archaeologists Sarah Newman and
Filipe roas are unearthing intriguing
clues that reveal how the surrounding
desert fed the people of
Petra it is baking now
yeah so this is one of them
yeah what you can see now that's above
ground is only about maybe a third of
what's
actually there so we
excavated sort of behind and in front of
the it goes down another sort of 2 m or
so so it goes 6 ft further down into the
ground at least yeah at least yeah at
some point this extended from Bedrock to
bedrock this recently discovered wall is
around 10 ft high and almost 1,000 ft
long sarin Felipe think it's a tiny part
part of an epic netin water distribution
system so it's a huge it's it's a dam
basically yeah what used to happen is
the water would come through the
mountains and be spread out by The
Terraces it's like um Stone linebackers
for Rushing Water yeah but this is not
just a flood defense slowing the Rushing
Water creates another
Advantage it sort of serves a dual
purpose in both kind of slowing the flow
of water but they also catch the
sediment that the water is bringing from
the mountains all the way down so this
soil it wasn't originally here this this
was from up there is that what you're
saying it got kind of pushed down with
time yeah it's it seems like they've
they figured out how to make nature work
for them right because by putting these
blocks here the rainwaters move the
Earth down here and essentially terar
aform for them
these Terraces filled with rich moist
soil make them perfect for cultivating
olives wheat fruit trees and
Vines sarin Felipe want to know how far
The Terraces
stretch using lar to scan the terrain
could help uncover new
information for the archaeologist
it's a battle against time erosion is
destroying the
evidence for us it's a battle against
the elements with 2 days of flying in
over 90°
Heat this is the dam that we were
at so zoom zoom further out please
y but can you see it it's this it's this
yeah can you see it from kind of yeah
let's try and look at it in a different
way yeah sort of manipulate the light
you can't see them with the naked eye so
you have to use
3D so these are The Terraces mhm these
are ancient Terraces yeah so I mean you
can see there's a bunch of terracing
here looks like there's some also coming
down here this sh makes them show up
really well is great yeah so this is the
first time you've seen it yeah yeah
absolutely so if you see that here where
we've done the scan it follows a natural
River bed and it would seem likely that
they would do that across all the
natural River beds across this Plateau
yeah so there's teres all the way up the
Watershed there's Terraces all the way
down and this is just one Watershed I
mean we know this is kind of a tiny part
of the scale of the management around
the City of Petra I mean that's that
shows that the site is really well
watered so what we're seeing
here is the reach of that thinking
turning the whole of this landscape
into an engineered
[Music]
Oasis today our liar data continues to
help sarin fipe discover more and more
Terraces in the hinderland of
Petra so far archaeologists have mapped
32,000 Acres of ancient
groundworks 70 sisters and 28 dams have
have been
uncovered 8 Miles Away snaking their way
through the mountains are channels and
catchment that once fed rain and
nutrients to
Petra 2,000 years ago the desert bloomed
green through the genius of the
[Music]
neans just can't ever get over the
beauty of this
place and I think it was built by people
who are just wandering the deserts a few
centuries
before from surviving on baren outcrops
to trading across deserts to ornate
monuments and frescos I have witnessed
the Ingenuity of the
neans it's their Mastery of water that
allowed to thrive and ultimately create
the ancient wonder that is
[Music]
Petra